there are many different phases of
sequence comparison in biology and we
will now learn some of them
we'll ask first the question what is
wrong with naive scoring models that we
used for the longest common subsequence
problem when we scored all matches by
one we saw the biologically adequate
alignment of our generation demands
constructed by Mary Hales but this
alignment is not the optimal longest
common subsequence
of this attenuation demand at the bottom
of the slide there is actually longest
common subsequence it has more matches
but it is biologically completely wrong
so the question arises how can we modify
the scoring for computing Kleinman's in
such a way that we avoid frivolous
matches that you can see in the bottom
alignment on this slide in the current
primitive scoring the simply compute
score as the number of matches let's
change it and let's also take into
account penalties for mismatches and
insertions and deletions so we give
premium one to every match and in our
alignment game we now give penalty new
to every mismatch and penalty Sigma to
every endo and as a result the score in
our alignment game changes before it was
for now it is minus seven how to find
optimal solution of the alignment gain
an optimal alignment under this model in
this case we essentially constructed the
scoring matrix which is five by five
matrix which describe the scorer for
matching every two symbols in the
extended alphabet which consists of
nucleotides plus the space symbol
and we can design for teller adversary
scoring matrices for example I design
and laboratory matrix here and we can
use it to play the alignment game
in fact biology invest biologists invest
a lot of effort into designing adequate
scoring matrices particularly scoring
matrices form in acid sequences and the
goal of the scoring matrices is to
reflect the mutation propensity of
different amino acid for example amino
acid why often mutates into F and that's
why it gets high score plus 7 but rarely
mutates in some other amino acids for
example prolene and in this case it gets
actually penalty minus 5 and this is an
example of scoring matrix that
biologists use now in the case V work of
these scoring matrices how our dynamic
programming Greek currency change so the
free currencies shown of the slide we
simply have the following pre currency s
IJ equal to four different possibilities
depending on whether we are computing
score for insertion deletion match or
mismatch as shown on the slide and the
scores of edges in the alignment graph
change accordingly as shown on this
slide or alternatively we can for very
general scoring matrix we simply can
write three terms recurrency where green
blue and red alternatives correspond to
vertical horizontal and diagonal edges
and global alignment problem that we
want to solve is the following one given
strings V and W and magic scorer we want
to find an alignment of the string whose
alignment score as the
by the scoring matrix his maximum among
all possible alignments of this snakes
global alignment is a good model for
some biological sequence comparison
problems but bad model for some others
and I'll give you an example of how my
Bob Jones to illustrate the challenges
of biological sequence comparison to
genes in different species may be
similar over short conserved regions and
dissimilar over remaining regions for
example homeobox genes have short
regions called the homer demand that is
highly conserved among specialists
varying from human to fly but global
alignment of horeb origins would not
reveal homeodomain because it would most
likely pass through completely every
region of the sequences since home
animals are short sub segments of homer
Bob Jones how can we find this important
biological similarity that however do
not extend over the entire length of
sequences and thus in this in the case
of search for this short sequences the
global alignment fails at this slide you
see two alignments and the question
arise with each alignment is better the
alignment on the top actually has a
higher score but the alignment at the
bottom has low score but more
biologically relevant because it shows
very strong match of short sequences how
can we find this alignment despite the
fact that global alignment may miss it
and search for such short segments
within sequences that extended
similarity is called the local alignment
problem so in this case there are two
possible alignments in the alignment
graph the alignment on the top is
biologically correct but the alignment
in the middle is actually random aligned
that however has a higher score from the
perspective of global alignment and
serve for a heights from us is
biologically relevant alignment so what
I want to do is to somehow find the
short substrings of the entire strength
that exhibit high similarity how do I do
this there is a very simple way to
search for short similar strength vision
long strength we can simply try all
possible pair of strengths from two
sequences and each such pair correspond
to a rectangle in the alignment graph
here's one of the rectangle but there
are so many such rectangles that this
approach of course becomes impractical
where since search for optimal global
alignment vision each small rectangle
requires quadratic time and therefore
overall the running time will become
very much what can we do to try to come
up with a practical local alignment
algorithm the first thing we need to do
is to formulate the local alignment
problem the input is strength V and W
and s current matrix score and output as
is substrings of the entire strength V
and W whose global alignment as defined
by scorer is maximum among all global
alignments of all sub strings of V and W
my proposal for solving this problem
let's introduce free taxi rights through
the alignment graph indeed if we were
able to start in the source and travel
freely to the start of the conserve
fragment and then take another free taxi
ride from the end of concered fragment
to the destination final note of the
alignment graph then we will be able to
score this interesting segment by taking
zero cost of taxi right to the beginning
of this fragment then real
cost of the alignment of the fragment
and then plus another zero which is the
cost of another taxi right you may ask
how in the world we can take taxi rides
through the lemon grass well the whole
point of introducing this concept of
Manhattan kind cities and travelling
Kingdom is that they are free to build
for tamil Manhattan like grids for
solving cowell biological problems and
in this case with what is a free taxi
ride
it's simply adding extra edges of weight
zero to our alignment graph and since
they are free to build whatever
Manhattan we want we can of course we
are at liberty of introducing this taxi
right so let's see how our graph change
what we need to do to implement this
free taxi right we need to add edges
from the source training as a node and
it will be roughly quadratic number of
edges we also need to add edges from
every node to the sent once again
pyretic number of edges so the number of
edges of the graph
remains quadratic and therefore our grid
will be fast and in the end how our
dynamic programming currency changed for
the local alignment before we had three
possibilities corresponding to three
ways to enter in node by vertical edge
by horizontal edge and by technology now
there is one more possibility we can
take a free taxi ride to the node so now
there are four possibilities for
entering every node which means that we
need to add the fourth term industry
currency which is the weight of edge
from 0 0 to I J and the weight of this
edge since our taxi rides are free is 0
and that the only change that we need to
implement to make our local alignment
algorithm and fast and we now move to
the problem of defining adequate
insertion and deletion penalties in
sequence like
you